hey good folks this is dr john delony
with ramsey network today we're going to
be talking about
counseling therapy what is it when
should i go
why should i go is it a scam is it just
lame
we're going to be talking about all that
stuff right so here we go during this
pandemic people are finding out
all sorts of things about themselves
we're not quite as tough as we thought
we were
or were way tougher than we thought we
were or our relationships
had more cracks in them than we wanted
to admit being locked down
from months on end with a partner that
we
didn't really like anymore or with kids
that we thought we liked we only saw
them two or three hours a day but now
that we see them all day
every day and they're always asking us
for a snack or
we're just finding out a lot about
ourselves right and on the more serious
side
suicides are up mental illness is up
anxiety depression people freaking out
holding on
to their sanity with dear life because
nothing feels stable
nothing feels in control millions of
people are out of work
it's just a chaotic time and then
there's just being alone for four
five six months that wreaks havoc on
every alarm system we have because we're
made to be in relationship
and connection with one another my wife
and two kids did a driveway visit the
other day with a woman from our church
she hasn't been physically touched by
another person
in six months can you imagine
not getting a high five or a hug or
bumping somebody in a hallway
this pandemic is wreaking havoc on our
mental health
and so you hear everybody say go get a
counselor i've got this new program i've
got an
app hey we got counseling online
everyone's mental health
is buzzing every influencer on the
internets
every news person every expert every
book author is saying
take care of your mental health go see a
counselor go see a therapist and so the
question people are asking is
should i go i don't know if i should go
i thought they were so lame and a bunch
of quacks and
i didn't think counseling was really
that was kind of dumb right so i want to
answer a couple of questions directly
and straightforward as i can and if you
have any further questions shoot them to
me at
askjohnramsiesolutions.com and i'll get
back in touch with you or i'll call you
in for
our radio show all right so what is
counseling
all counseling is is a professional
helping
relationship that's it most counselors
in most states
can be counselors marriage and family
therapists
social workers a different kind of
profession but similar is a psychologist
and then medical doctors who can
prescribe medicine are called
psychiatrists right
these mental health professionals or
counselors are trained to walk alongside
folks
in their good times and their bad times
helping you walk through challenges
that you may not have the skills or
expertise or wisdom to walk through
or to help you revisit traumas from the
past
help you work through challenges that
have lodged themselves in your
physical body and your spiritual body
and your mental body
counselors are not your friends they're
not your buddies
they're not your future romantic partner
they're professional
sherpas they walk alongside you they're
guides a counselor reflects to you
who you are out in the real world they
reflect back to you how they experience
you
are you quiet and reserved and nervous
are you loud and annoying and abrasive a
counselor should call you on your bs
they should hold a mirror up to you and
let you get to meet you
sometimes for the first time or
sometimes for the 10th
20th and 30th time and a counselor
should teach you new skills
and practice those skills with you
skills like
how to get over social anxiety how to
talk in public
and not let your heart beat out of your
chest right how to
be more present in relationships how to
work through addictions
any number of challenges how to not be
scared of snakes or
heights how to like what you see in the
mirror how to get a good
night sleep because we all deserve
a good night's sleep and i believe in
terrence real's
relational therapy and i believe in
terrence reel's model of therapy
that a counselor can't be neutral
anymore
counselors were trained to be neutral to
not judge
to just listen and absorb and reflect
and there is
times when a counselor needs to step in
and say your behavior is hurting people
especially in a relationship your
behavior is hurting her
the way you're treating him hurts him
and so sometimes
a counselor is not neutral but they're
always walking alongside you
helping you on your journey so when
should you go to counseling
i believe everyone could benefit
from some time with a neutral second
party or if you're in a relationship
from a neutral third party and if you're
watching this and you just thought
already no stupid counselor you for sure
need to go
and if you just thought oh i don't need
you for sure for sure need to go
you for sure need to go because you're
talking back to a youtube video man
that says that you probably got some
stuff in your heart that you need to
work through right
but i recommend that everybody go meet
with somebody
that they can be vulnerable with
completely vulnerable and honest with
open with have someone that challenges
them someone that
bounces their thoughts back to them
someone that helps them be better in
relationships
sometimes that's a mentor sometimes
that's a friend or a guide or a pastor
and sometimes that's a professional
a counselor a psychologist a marriage
and family therapist
one of my mentors dr aretha marbley once
said the biggest challenge in counseling
is people wait till they are in
absolute crisis before they go and we
know from brain science that when people
are in crisis
it's hard for them to hear it's hard for
them to think because their mind is on
automatic protection mode right she
likened it to
wait until you have the flu to go sign
up and start a new weight loss program
at the gym
that's the worst time to go work out so
if you've wondered about why you do the
things you do
if you've got trauma in your past that
you'd really like to work through
if every time you see folks that look
like him
or sound like her your heart rates you
get nervous or if
every time after date three or four you
just break up
so you can get away from her before she
hurts you or if you're a person of anger
and rage or frustration or you just want
to dig
into your past go see a counselor
what's it gonna hurt right what's it
gonna hurt
and i think everyone everyone who's
considering marriage
should go see a marriage counselor
should go see a neutral third party
that can bring you closer together help
you discuss things help you negotiate
things help you
learn to co-create your future vision
together
with expertise and with wisdom everyone
and this is coming from someone who
didn't go to premarital counseling
and my marriage almost paid the price
for it several times over
we should have you should too another
reason to go see a counselor
is physical symptoms do you have a
stomach ache that just
won't go away and the doctors tell you
man we just there's nothing here
or you've got headaches and the doctor
says man i don't
i don't see anything neurologically your
scans came back well
or you're not sleeping trauma has a way
of wiring itself into our bodies
into our histories going to sit down
with a marriage and family therapist
going to sit down with a social worker
going to sit down with a counselor may
uncover parts about your physiology
that your spirit has bound up that your
experiences
have bound up and with the right work it
can set you free
so what should i look for in a counselor
number one
a counselor should be warm joyful
welcoming they shouldn't judge you
even if they say what you're doing
stupid that's different than saying
you're stupid right
they should walk alongside you they
should be completely and totally
confidential and they should spell that
out for you
they should be in a private safe
location
and they should present you with some
very firm boundaries
tell you where to call if you have an
emergency in the middle of the night
tell you where to go if you have a
mental health crisis
you probably should not be texting or
emailing or calling
your therapist back and forth all the
time
that borders on an inappropriate
relationship
most importantly a counselor should be a
great listener
and they should tell you the truth
what are some things to look out for in
a counselor you should not be in
counseling forever
this isn't a lifetime commitment a
counselor should walk with you
teach you new skills help you practice
new skills
help you examine past traumas and learn
to live in the present moving forward
they can sometimes help you create a
plan for what tomorrow might look like
but counseling is not a forever
adventure you may check back in in a
year
check back in a few years but a
counselor who says
we're in this for the long haul is
probably not an ethical counselor
i know there's different kinds of
modalities like psychoanalytics and deep
family work
i get that but most of the time
you should not be in counseling forever
also watch out for counselors who try to
diagnose you within the first few
minutes of meeting you
we are way more complex than our
diagnosis
and i know it's frustrating for
therapists to get reimbursed from
insurance because they have to diagnose
you to get that reimbursement
but i want you to be very careful about
what goes in your medical records
because those never
change and they follow you and be really
careful about
a counselor who meets you and asks you
three questions how long you been
feeling bad
on a scale of one to five how bad are
you feeling do you want to keep feeling
like this well i
hereby diagnose you i bequeath you with
someone needs to meet with you several
times they need to get to know you get
to understand your experiences
before they label you permanently with
some sort of medical diagnosis
and i know i've said this in past videos
you are not your diagnosis
that is not your identity and i'm going
to stop right here otherwise i'm gonna
get on a soapbox
also don't go to a counselor who's a
jerk
the most important aspect of counseling
more important than where they went to
grad school who their professors were
who their friends were what fancy books
they read the most
important thing about counseling is the
relationship
between the counselor and the client
between you
and your therapist that's the most
important thing
so if somebody's rude they're pompous
they feel like they are very much better
than you
you turn around and walk out the door
because you've got to be able to trust
them you've got to be able to be
vulnerable and finally
a trained therapist should not dig into
the details
and gory past of your traumas
in the first session or the second
session or the third session and beyond
if you are going to counseling to dig
into past traumas to work through some
things that have happened to you over
the past that should take several
sessions and in those sessions a good
counselor is going to discuss with you a
safety plan
teach you how to relax teach you some
coping behaviors when they start to
remove the crutches that you've been
leaning on for most of your life
that doesn't happen in session one so
where do you find a counselor or other
mental health professional
they are everywhere they can be found
online with like zoom counseling
that has taken a sharp uptick the last
few months because of covet and i'm
hearing great things coming out of some
of those sessions
you can find counselors in college towns
with interns
and laboratories on campus where
programs in marriage and family therapy
and social work
and addictions counseling and clinical
counseling
psychology are all trying to get hours
for their student interns
and they are usually at a much reduced
or free
rate or you can ask a friend many of the
people around you
are seeing counselors and you don't even
know it they're quietly talking to
somebody offline they're quietly in
marriage counseling and they just don't
want to talk about it
it may be a good conversation for you
guys to partner up and
join in vulnerability with one another
in recent years many churches have added
free counseling or reduced cost
counseling for their members or for
their local communities
and so local churches are a great place
to look too and finally
community counseling centers can be
found all across the country
in towns both big and small and
everywhere in between
community counseling centers often offer
counseling
at reduced cost low cost or even free
depending on your economic situation
i did an internship in a community
counseling clinic and i was blown away
by how much the counselors
the interns and the staff loved the
clients
loved that community and really dug into
some hard challenging things with folks
who otherwise didn't have the money to
pay
it was wonderful wonderful care and i
wouldn't think twice about recommending
a local community counseling center to
someone who i love or to a family member
so counselors are awesome social workers
marriage and family therapists
psychologists they are here to help you
when your relationships get fractured
when your spirit and heart get fractured
when you're trying to figure out why you
don't have memories of your childhood
or you just want peace
so i strongly recommend go find a
counselor go talk to somebody
if you are starting to get out of whack
make that phone call
this is dr john delany with ramsey
network subscribe to this channel
send this video to somebody who's been
talking about counseling
thinking i don't know if i should send
the video and encourage them to go
follow me at john delony and if you have
any questions about counselors
the right ones if you want to tell me
about some horror stories i'll read them
here on the show
email me at ask john ramseysolutions.com
take care